in this lesson we're going to talk about
how to find the interior and the
exterior angle in a regular polygon so
what exactly is a regular polygon well
it's a polygon where all the sides are
the same length and all the angles have
the same measurement so we're going to
use two formulas in this lesson we're
going to use the N minus 2 times 180
which is equal to the sum of the
interior angles so all these angles on
the inside added up together and then
we're also going to make use of the fact
that the sum of all the exterior angles
in a polygon always add up to 360 no
matter how many sides there are no
matter how many angles there are so just
to kind of illustrate why does this
formula work
if you were to take like say for example
a pentagon a pentagon has five sides or
five angles you can subdivide it into
how many triangles well you can see
there's one two three triangles and you
learned earlier in Geometry how in a
triangle all these angles are going to
add up to 180 degrees but if you have
three triangles
times 180 that's going to be 540 degrees
and so what we're doing is you can see
there's always two less triangles than
the number of sides in the polygon so
that's why this formula works now for
the exterior angles what an exterior
angle is is say you have like a little
triangle like this
if you extend one of the sides of the
polygon it doesn't matter whether you
extend this side or this side just one
side at each vertex
the exterior angle is the angle that's
formed between that extended side and
the polygon so you can see here
that we have three exterior angles and
what it does is it forms like a circle
360 degrees so no matter how many sides
how many angles the exterior angles will
always add up to 360. so let's go
through some examples now and talk about
how can you exactly find the measure of
just one of the interior angles in a
regular polygon and one of the exterior
angles so there's a couple different
ways to do this let's start off by
working with a regular hexagon so we
know a hexagon has six sides six angles
so one way to do this is we could say
six minus two is four
times 180 degrees
is equal to
720 degrees so that means that all these
angles here on the inside of this
hexagon are going to add up
together to 720 degrees but how many
angles do we have we have six angles so
if we were to divide this by six you can
see that each one of these angles would
be 120 degrees 120 120 Etc
now we've got the interior angle how do
we find the exterior angle well a simple
way is just to extend
one of these sides like so and you can
see that this forms a line and we're
going to have two angles that form what
we call a linear pair so linear means
line pair means two and so these two
angles have to add up to 180
so that means that the exterior angle
equals 60 degrees now another way that
you could approach this is that you can
say I know that all the exterior angles
add up to 360 degrees so if I was to
extend one of the sides on each
at each vertex of this hexagon
I can say well they all add up to 360.
so if I just take 360 Degrees divided by
6 that comes out to 60 degrees and then
once I have that exterior angle I can
then just subtract from 180 to find the
interior angle again keep in mind this
is just for regular polygons where all
the sides are congruent all the angles
are congruent let's take a look at
another example so for example number
two let's take a look at a regular
decagon so decagon is like decade 10
years in a decade and we don't always
know how to draw some of these polygons
but what we can do is we can draw like
one angle in the polygon and just kind
of sketch out the rest of it it doesn't
have to be exact we're mainly focused on
just this one angle so again two
different options this time what I'm
going to do is I'm going to start with
the exterior angle so I'm going to
extend this side I'm going to look at
this exterior angle and I know that all
the exterior angles always add up to
360 degrees so let's go ahead and take
360 Degrees
divided by the 10 exterior angles and
that's going to give us a measure of
36 degrees for our exterior angle now
all we have to do since this forms a
line a line linear pair this interior
angle is going to be 180 minus 36
degrees which comes out to
144 degrees so that's one option the
other option is to go to our some of our
interior angles formula and let's do n
minus 2 times 180. so in this case
there's 10 angles so we're going to say
10 minus 2.
times 180
which gives us 8 times 180
which let's go to the calculator I
believe that's
1440.
but remember that's the sum of all the
interior angles we just want one
interior angle so if we divide that by
10 that comes out to 144 degrees then
all you have to do is subtract from 180
and you have your exterior angle let's
take a look at one more example so
before we dive into example number three
which is like a word problem I just
wanted to mention that if you're
interested in some more of my content
I've got an algebra one and an Algebra 2
video course for sale I'll put a link in
the description below if you want to
check that out if you're studying
algebra algebra 2 college algebra check
those courses out and if you just want
to support the channel and just help out
what I'm doing here on YouTube consider
joining as a channel member so for a few
dollars a month you can help support the
channel and I really appreciate it so
for example number three it says find
the number of sides in a regular polygon
if the measure of one of the interior
angles is 168
so this is an interesting problem
because we're actually working backwards
to find the number of sides or the
number of angles in this regular polygon
so let's go ahead and set this up two
different ways the first way is
n minus 2
times 180 is the sum of all the interior
angles but if we divide by the number of
interior angles that'll give us the
measure of just one interior angle so
let's go ahead and solve this equation
what I would do is I would multiply both
sides by n that way the numerator and
denominator here cancel whatever you do
to the left you want to do to the right
then what I would do is I would
distribute this 180 degrees into the
parenthesis so that gives us 180 n minus
360 is equal to 168 n
then I would subtract 180 N I want to
get the variables on one side numbers on
the other it's just a basic algebra
equation
and so you can see we're getting
negative 360 is equal to
negative 12 and and then if we divide
both sides by negative 12
n is coming out to 30. so what we have
here is a 30
gone basically meaning this is a polygon
with 30 sides or 30 angles now this took
a little bit of time so there's another
shortcut method that you can do which is
to focus on the
this formula here that all the exterior
angles add up to 360. and so if we know
the interior angle is 168
180 minus 168 gives us the exterior
angle of 12 degrees so what we're going
to do now is we're going to say 360
which is the sum of the exterior angles
divided by the number of exterior angles
which we don't know yet equals the
measure of just one of the exterior
angles now all we have to do is multiply
both sides by n
and you can see we have 12n equals 360
and if we divide both sides of that
equation by 12
you can see that n is coming out to 30.
same exact answer so two different ways
to approach that so if you want to see
some more examples where I'm talking
about working with polygons I'll put a
video for you right there follow me over
to that video and we'll get some more
practice I'll see you there